this year's nobel prize was won by two
chemists benjamin liszt from germany and
david macmillan originally from scotland
but whose scientific career has been in
america and it is based on a field
called organocatalysis
using organic molecules as catalysts and
using them very specifically for making
molecules of one hand rather than the
other
because
organic molecules have a carbon atom
that is surrounded by four groups
if those four groups are all different
they can be arranged in two ways which
are mirror images of each other you can
see the mirror images in these two dog
toys here that look really similar but
you can't arrange them in the same
position
so you have two molecules which are
chemically identical but have different
arrangement of atoms in space
and the difficulty for chemists
is to make one of them
rather than the other so why should you
want to make one rather than the other
and the answer is that the different
handed molecules can have different
properties
at the nobel announcement the person
explaining what the price was for
pointed out that a lemon
and an orange
have the same chemicals in them called
limonene but different handedness so the
limonene in the lemon makes it smell of
lemon and in the orange makes it smell
of oranges in nature
inside my body inside your body
we have enzymes which are really quite
complicated molecules
that can make
molecules of one hand rather than the
other they act as catalysts they bring
together the reactants so that they
react to make the handed molecule you
want this type of catalysis uses very
very simple molecules that you can take
from biology take from nature
to inspire and to drive chemical
processes
so unlike other natural materials things
like enzymes these molecules are really
small
small molecules with masses of about 100
to 150 mass units sometimes a little bit
larger but not much larger not like a
protein which is thousands of atomic
mass units so the benefits are that
energy consumption is reduced
that atom efficiency is increased and
that we don't make lots and lots of
wastes and and
waste lots of atoms which other types of
catalysis can actually do
now the breakthrough that these two
chemists made was to realize that you
can select molecules which you find in
the enzymes that catalyze a particular
reaction in the case of benjamin list
it was a sort of reaction called the
aldol reaction where you bring two
aldehydes together and there's an enzyme
that catalyzes this reaction and just a
bit of that enzyme is a molecule called
proline and what benjamin list showed
was that using proline by itself you
could also get a catalytic reaction and
produce one molecule rather than the
other this was a huge breakthrough
the proline didn't react
terribly well it wasn't a very good
catalyst
but
it demonstrated the principle
so this is proline it's one of the
molecules that's been used by um listen
macmillan or one of the types of
molecules and it's an amino acid so it's
a building block of protein one of the
glories of that is it's readily
available
it comes as a single enantiomer so
one-handed form
and it's non-toxic so we eat about five
or six grams apparently
a day and our bodies can produce it as
well proline is only one of the
molecules that's been used as an organo
catalyst it's certainly one of the first
molecules that was used
but it really represents a whole class
and sort of the
the original
compound which then people have
developed and built on so this is a very
obvious one to go to because it is in
proteins and it's something that we can
all relate to in that sense you know
chemists using and simplifying
nature's highly sophisticated machinery
to their own ends
at a nobel prize ceremony they try and
get one of the prize winners online so
they can answer questions and benjamin
list
said that
when he thought of the idea
he first all thought somebody must have
tried it before
but he couldn't find any record so he
tried it
and when he worked he realized it was
probably something pretty important
david macmillan used a different
reaction so-called diels alder reaction
which involves bringing two organic
molecules together and he also found a
catalyst quite independently which would
do this so you get one hand rather than
the other in chemical terms this is
called enantioselectivity
and once
these discoveries have been made and
they were made about 20 years ago
then
people realized it was possible
and lots of people started researching
they have now found
better and better catalysts
and some of those catalysts are now much
better
than naturally occurring enzymes
and you can do the reactions
much faster and get things
which you cannot get with enzymes other
people have worked on
this kind of thing before but
listen macmillan have certainly really
pushed the field forward and opened it
up for others to come in and develop it
and have you know opened up a whole new
generation of researchers
actually when i heard the prize my mind
fleeted back through my career to to
friends and
and really important friends people like
carlos barbus who who worked with ben in
some of the earlier days and the
contributions of these people who are
sadly no longer with us and the
contributions of the future will really
drive the impact of not only organic
catalysis but other types of sustainable
chemistry
[Applause]
some people say
that winning the nobel prize
is the biggest disaster that can happen
to a scientist of course it's a
wonderful glory that you've won the
prize and a huge honor on the other hand
as soon as you win the nobel prize
everybody wants you to give lectures you
become a public figure
and a lot of people a lot of nobel prize
winners don't have any time really to do
more science they're spending all their
time being a public figure so
if you want to be a really successful
and productive scientist
might be better not to win the nobel
prize
here at berkeley
they have parking spaces reserved just
for nobel laureates
so how do you prove you're a noble
lawyer do you have to have to put your
medal on the dashboard
this is what you get when you win the
nobel prize it's a real nobel prize
medal made of gold i think brady was
hoping that i'd be mugged on the way so
that he could have a good story
scientist loses nobel prize